doctor doctor my partner says they're
gonna leave me if i don't stop doing
borah impressions
who's your partner my wife so
bora to or that borat subsequent movie
film
delivery of prodigious bride to american
regime will make benefit
once glorious nation of kazakhstan to
give it its full name
is now out online and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the most controversial moments from the
movie
i just want to get straight into it but
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't seen the film yet
then i highly recommend that you stick
around for the video
not terrible i promise i'll stop with
the terrible jokes now
with that out the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
14 years ago
borat released his first movie which
ended up making kazakhstan look so bad
that it tanked the country's value of
potassium and pubis
borat was sentenced to the gulag but
after he's given a special mission to
drop a gift off to michael pence
he returns to the good old u.s of a with
his daughter
now this gift is originally supposed to
be a monkey but after borat's daughter
tuta eats it
borat decides to hand her over instead
things go awry
and after he fails to deliver her to
pence he switches his attention to rudy
giuliani
now unless you've been living under a
rock in the glorious nation of
kazakhstan
you've probably seen the major
controversy surrounding this
in the film borat's daughter tutor poses
as a journalist
and starts interviewing giuliani on
camera in a hotel room
she says it's a dream come true and
giuliani
seems very receptive to her aura even
drops in a little subtle joke about rudy
duty marrying his own cousin
which flies under the radar now speaking
of flies
not long after giuliani is seen lying on
the bed
putting his hand in his pants and almost
pulling his fly down oh look i'm sorry
i'll
i'll stop with the bad puns i swear
hello now in the footage
giuliani also tells tutor that she can
give him
her phone number and address and he also
seems to be fiddling with
address namely his sorry promise no more
now before it goes any further
borat bursts into the room saying that
his daughter is only 15
and that she's too old for him in the
aftermath rudy apparently called the
police
and since then he said that he was
simply tucking his shirt into his pants
it's at this moment that i actually
realized i've been tucking my shirt in
wrong
my entire life yikes no but this is
clearly going to be debated for a long
long time
and since the reviews for the film
dropped there's been a lot of coverage
surrounding the event
in all honesty it is quite difficult to
make out and rudy himself stated that
it's been heavily edited in order to
incriminate him
on twitter giuliani stated the borat
video is a complete fabrication
i was tucking in my shirt after taking
off the recording equipment
and no time before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate
if sasha baron cohen implies otherwise
he is a stone cold liar
in fact the ny post today reports it
looks to me like an exaggeration through
editing
as soon as i realized i was set up i
called the police
which has been noted in a thr article on
july 8th
this is an effort to blunt my relentless
exposure of the criminality and
depravity of joe biden
and his entire family deadline reports
caa had a distribution screening in
september
where there was no mention of the scene
holding any importance
we are preparing much bigger dumps off
of the hard drive from hell
of which joe biden will be unable to
defend or hide from
i have the receipts alright mate keep
your pants on
damn me now in the aftermath of it the
police didn't go any further with the
investigation
but giuliani has faced a lot of backlash
over the last couple of days
especially as this is in the run-up to
the election now i don't care who you
vote for
at all and by that i mean you should
vote kanye
but either way it's brought a lot of
negative press around the figure over
the last week
in all honesty i hate every politician
as much as the next guy
but when it comes to interviews like
this microphones are often shoved up
through people's shirts
so it does seem likely that he wasn't
plugging it
we also know there's a point in the
interview in which audio issues are
raised
so the story does make sense and police
haven't investigated it further
now borat rushes in before anything
actually happens
but due to the way it's framed and the
music it's likely going to be something
that people speculate over for a long
time
now i can't see it damaging his career
that much in the long run
and if the politics of the past year or
anything to go off it it'll be forgotten
by the next scandal
in about three hours time now on top of
this the creative team were also sued by
the family of holocaust survivor
judith dim evans unfortunately evans
passed away before the film's release
today
but that hasn't stopped her daughter
from speaking out against it evans's
daughter claimed that the comedy mock
jewish culture
and the genocide of her people in the
second world war baron cohen himself is
jewish
and he actually stated that evans was
included to mock holocaust deniers
as we know that part of borat's
character is that he doesn't like the
race
the creative team stated that she was
clued in on the gag
however her daughter has refuted this
and said that she was horrified and
upset
to learn that her mother would be part
of a satirical comedy that dealt with
such matters
baron cohen apparently broke character
before the scene
and informed evans of what it was
actually going to be used for in the
film
unfortunately she passed away so never
got to see it
and evans family attorney has stated
that they haven't seen the footage
either
honestly when you watch the film i think
it just sounds like a big
misunderstanding
and amazon have actually included bonus
content about her story
and dedicated the film to her baron
cohen is very outspoken against
anti-semitism
and the actor is involved with the
anti-defamation league
the scene in the film basically involves
borat dressing up as what he views as a
jew
and realizing that his stereotypes are
wrong i actually think that the scene is
quite touching
and evans comes across as a sweet old
lady when you look into her real story
it's horrendous what happened to her and
i don't think that the film is making
fun of her at all
rather it's the people with bigoted
views that they're lampooning
now on top of this the film also brings
up several significant political moments
including justin trudeau wearing
blackface and several controversies
surrounding donald trump
there's also a disney s cartoon that
makes fun of
of his grab her by the p word comments
and all together
it's filled with a lot of social
commentary like this baron cohen also
dresses up in a kkk robe
and slips into a republican conference
in addition to this there's a doctor
admitting that he would do a sex attack
on tattoo
if her father wasn't there ambora ends
up spending a couple of days with a
group of republicans
baron cohen told the new york times that
he had to remain in character the entire
time
and we see as they discuss things that
they believe about hillary clinton
including that she drinks the blood of
children well i wouldn't bloody put it
past her
talking about his time with them cohen
said the following
it was the hardest thing i had to do i
was waking up having breakfast lunch and
dinner
and going to sleep sleepers bora when i
lived in the house with these two
conspiracy theorists
you can't have a moment out of character
now you may remember that in the
aftermath of the first film
kazakhstan sued the creative team the
villagers of glad in romania also took
action against the film
along with several people who lost their
jobs due to appearing in it
now whether this happens over borat 2
remains to be seen
but i have to say that if they get sued
again it was kind of worth it
now the film ends with it being revealed
that borah is actually the super
spreader of kovid 19
which was created by kazakhstan and
passed through america
and australia through tom hanks who we
now call it in the country
it's an incredible twist and probably
the perfect
way to end the film in my opinion now i
think that the movie is absolutely
hilarious
and i never thought that a sequel would
live up to the first movie
but i actually think that it's better i
can't wait to rewatch this
and i hope you enjoyed the video as well
i would obviously
love to hear your thoughts on the film
and the most controversial scenes in
your opinion
i know there's a lot out there on the
movie but i thought i'd just go into the
ones from the film that are currently
making the headlines
if you enjoyed the video then please
drop a thumbs up i will chop you up like
this so
i caught i'm sorry i could and make sure
you check out our breakdown of rebecca
which is gonna be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i'll be paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
um